départ réduction éloignement la
polémique sur la fin de fonction de la
préfète Marie Lajus en Indre-et-Loire
repart de plus belle depuis la
publication sur les réseaux sociaux de
cette vidéo à l'occasion de son pot de
départ Marie lajuse brandit un
exemplaire du Canard enchaîné à
l'intérieur un article qui annonce que
Gérald de Darmanin aurait démissionné la
préfète à la demande sous la pression
des élus locaux depuis une pétition
Marie lajuste une préfète intègre et
lancée sur Internet qui réunit 355
signatures
Bernard Gauthier le président de
l'association des mers ruraux
d'Indre-et-Loire n'a ni signé la
pétition ni Oeuvray pour un départ
précipité de la préfète il lui reconnaît
une fermeté et un respect de la loi est
considère que la préfète n'a pas laissé
de marge de manœuvre aux élus locaux
elle était
pas très à l'écoute j'ai trouvé pas sur
le plan sur le plan relationnel
n'allez pas vers les gens il fallait
vraiment aller vers elle
l'interpeller quand on lui écrivait elle
ne répondait pas
c'était quand même un peu gênant bon les
services ne répondaient évidemment quand
on s'adressait à eux fin de fonction
sans nouvelles affectation la démarche
se ressemble à une sanction d'autant que
le décret est pris en conseil des
ministres le jour même du Congrès des
Maires d’indre-et-loire le départ est
politique c'est sûr le jour de l'article
du cadavre enchaîné j'étais en conseil
municipal à Tours Emmanuel Denis a été
dithyrambique à son égard donc il y a un
vrai voilà le rapport préféré on l'a dit
notamment pendant le confinement pendant
le covid c'est ce qui fait l'état
aujourd'hui par contre ce ce duo là
c'est ce il fonctionnait plus il
fonctionnait pas depuis qu'elle était là
pendant deux ans et demi de présence
dans le département Marie lajusse peut
mettre à son crédit une lutte sans
relâche contre les violences faites aux
femmes et un soutien sans faille au
démarche qui pousse à l'égalité
homme-femme Justine Dubourg et
présidente de Touraine woman association
pour rendre visible les femmes de
l'économie tourangelle elle a pu
constater en engagement fort non un
militantisme de la préfète contre le
sexisme non l'ensemble des discours que
j'ai pu entendre de Marie Régis on
sentait à la fois une connaissance
réelle du sujet ce qui fait du bien
quand on est des fonceuse de cette cause
là autour de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes mais on sentait aussi un
réel partage et une réelle pédagogie
autour de ce sujet même dans des
endroits où on n'attendait pas forcément
sur ça et ou plutôt le discours était un
peu l'inverse et en fait elle a moi j'ai
trouvé qu'elle avait le courage de dire
la réalité de la situation difficile
voire impossible de faire l'unanimité
quand les préfets ou préfet en fonction
les salutations et les compliments ne
viennent qu'au moment du départ dans les
coutumes républicaines Marie lajusse
n'aura pas connu ce plaisir là en créant
une nouvelle querelle politique dans le
département